for a guy like you my guess would be you
know having king of queens and shows
like that allows you then to go do the
things that you want to do yes king of
queens is the reason that i was able to
do stuff like comedians of comedy um it
gave me that a solid enough basis that i
could go and do smaller clubs where i
wasn't making a lot of money but i was
building the fan base that i needed so i
was very very fortunate you know to have
shows like that but also
king of queens was a blast to do all the
writers were stoners they were always
pulling weird pranks there's the one
episode where they dared me to stand
still in a sea there's a scene where i'm
in it but i don't have any lines they
went
do not move the whole scene see if we
can get away with it see if anyone catch
it and there's a scene
i am completely immobile through the
whole scene and they were always like
sneaking weird phrases and and also just
getting to watch
kevin james jerry stroller leah remini
they're such amazing tv actors and that
was something that i wasn't good at tv
acting is really hard
very hard to make it look natural why
it's such an unnatural setting it's so
each scene is its own little thing um
okay cut neck set up and you have to
also then pause for the laughs um but
make it seem like that's part of the
conversation it is a very unnatural art
form that the truly great
actors tv actors like danny devito and
kelsey grammer um and you know that they
can really really deliver that and make
it look so natural it's very hard to do
and kevin's one of them kevin
there are moments in that show that he
doesn't even have dialogue just the way
that he reacts to things are so
hilarious